I'm really happy to be here today and as
many people have commented just in this
fantastically beautiful space and while
we're thinking about the space I want to
actually ask you to consider not just
the the physicality of the space but the
setting and the way that we're relating
to each other in this space it's a
familiar setting right it's one that we
kind of all grew up in where there's one
person on stage maybe two people at a
time
sharing ideas and the majority of people
in the room are listening hopefully
engaged but listening and this kind of
setting is really similar to many
lecture halls and classrooms all across
colleges and universities in this
country rooms like this one and this one
and increasingly sometimes like this one
and if you look and you think about this
setting these spaces say a lot about
some of our fundamental beliefs about
how people learn these rooms say that we
learn while sitting down while listening
paying attention to the person expert in
the front of the room the proverbial
sage on the stage
many of these rooms can only be arranged
in just that one configuration the
furnitures bolted to the ground and
designed in such a way to limit
interaction between most of the people
in the room they encourage us to write
down and record what we're hearing for
future study or reference and what these
rooms convey what they say about what we
believe about how people learn and how
we should teach these ideas are very
very very old they're at least 800 years
old clearly they come from someplace
even older so eight hundred years ago
was around the first the time that the
first universities were emerging in
Europe and what this means is that
nearly everyone who works at or teaches
at a college or university
today was educated in this model and so
these basic ideas have been with us for
a long time and they're going to be very
hard to change but we are in the middle
of a debate in this country about the
value and the cost on the form even of
our higher education so one area of
scrutiny right now is the admissions
process to get into college today
you have to have straight A's and AP
classes and spectacular scores and
really evocative personal essays and
lead a community service club and play
varsity sports and have a black belt in
karate and I could go on I'm not I'm not
even exaggerating and what we're
essentially creating is this extremely
industrious army of high schoolers who
are trying very very hard to fit that
one narrow definition of what it looks
like to be successful so one voice in
this debate is a former professor from
Yale named William DeRosa woods and he
writes about his concern that were
essentially training a generation of
young people to be good at jumping
through hoops and conforming
intellectually in other words he writes
are we just producing really excellent
sheep now I want you to look at the
image on the screen and think about your
own college experience for a second I'm
curious if anyone else sees themselves
on the screen I do did anyone else here
go to college right after high school
and work really diligently to make sure
that you got through in the right amount
of time in four years I did I like a lot
of students was really good and
conscientious about following those
rules of school I never questioned could
it be different now others of you may
not see yourselves in this image but may
recognize some of your former classmates
or your colleagues or your kids
particularly if they're going through
the admissions process right now maybe
you found that the conventional model
didn't work for you but you persisted
anyway but this is really the kind of
model that's being held up as the brass
ring that we should all aspire to in
this country now this kind of hot topic
in higher ed has been playing out in the
media all summer - Reza woods published
an excerpt of his new book in The New
Republic that got a ton of attention it
was called don't send your kid to the
Ivy League and it showed a picture of
the Harvard flag in flames which was not
very popular at Harvard but it got over
2 million hits online it was drew a lot
of attention and his perspective is
really controversial so a lot of people
don't think and particularly some of the
students that he's describing with this
metaphor don't think it's fair to hold
them responsible for the failings of the
overall system or to somehow criticize
them just because they work very hard
and try to achieve success in the way
that our society currently defines it
but I believe that Reza whit's is
writing with genuine concern for this
generation of students whom he describes
as the kid that everyone wants at their
college but no one wants in their
classroom the student who will have much
success but little vision and the kid
who works very very hard but rarely
questions Authority and I actually
believe that this is a problem that we
should all be interested in because this
is a generation of students who are
incredibly highly structured but they're
going to be entering an increasingly
ambiguous world it's the most complex
ambiguous world we've ever known right
this is the world of Ebola and Isis and
climate change and data security
breaches but it's also this world a
tremendous opportunity to make really
transformative change as many of you are
doing through technology and design and
industry and science and so we need to
be training our students not just to
expect that they will be society's
leaders but also to be our most creative
daring and resilient problem solvers so
I think it's really important to ask can
the current system of higher education
produce it can the current system that
we have actually produce
thinkers and problem solvers so the
ecosystem in academia and the culture is
a really old one it's not built to
change or adapt rapidly but there are
these two pressures that are happening
right now that are kind of starting to
get people off of off balance and to
shake things up a little bit so one is
the abundance of new technology is
starting to make us ask questions about
what is the meaning of online learning
and what does it mean to higher
education right what is it gonna mean
when a student arrives for the first day
as a freshman and she's already taken
all of the entry classes online or even
better what if students who have learned
using some of the tools that Jake was
showing earlier that's what they are
used to in an elementary school on high
school and then they arrive and they
come to our lecture rooms right this is
going to happen soon this change the
other thing that's happening at the same
time is a real question and a set of
concerns about the cost and the social
and economic value of a college degree
and this is a really important question
for us to grapple with particularly
because in this country have always had
this goal that college is supposed to
help establish social mobility but at
the moment most efforts around
innovation in higher ed have focused
squarely around online learning and
until very recently particularly around
MOOCs right this idea that we could have
these massive classrooms online
accessible to everyone around the world
so at the Stanford d.school we were
really curious to look and see what was
happening in the other direction so over
the past year we wrestled with this
question what is the future of the
on-campus experience in the age of
online learning and we brought students
like something that you see here and
faculty and designers together at the
d.school to really look at this question
together what is so special and
important about being in person while
you're learning being together living in
the community where you're learning that
students will even choose to enroll in a
residential college experience in the
future so the first thing that we did
was we wanted to really try to
understand real
students experiences now and so we
equipped our students with video cameras
and we sent them out on campus to
interview their peers and get some of
these stories so I'm gonna show you a
very short video of a student named
Becca who was a senior when this video
was shot and Becca was a student who had
really struggled and felt conflicted
about her choice of major and finally
actually to break through this this
feeling of struggle she did something
kind of radical she just stepped out of
the system she took a year off and she
worked in a professional capacity she
worked on a political campaign so this
is Becca and I just want to say this
video was shot by one of our students in
a dorm I think late at night
the quality is not great but if you
listen what Becca talks about in terms
of her personal journey and this real
transformation that she experienced
after coming back from her year off it's
pretty it's pretty interesting the first
thing for me is that like this year
probably actually took a year off I came
back and this is the first time that I I
feel like I've actually like taking
control of my education in a meaningful
way not like a meaningful way in the arc
of Education but a meaningful way in
like the arc of my life in the arc of
like learning things in life so I have
no longer I have really incentives to
get good grades and my grades are better
than they've ever been and I no longer
have incentives really to like feel like
I need to take a specific class and I
like my classes more than I've ever
liked them before and I do more of the
work it's as times than I ever have
before and I enjoy it a lot more okay so
if you're an educator that's what you
want to hear you want to hear I do more
of my work than ever before and I enjoy
it more right she's getting more out of
it and we want more Becca's Becca is a
student who stepped out of that line
right she had to figure out how to hack
the system and we actually heard many of
these stories of students who didn't
really find that reason for their
education they didn't have that sense of
ownership until they did something that
was kind of different than the status
quo different than the expectations
and actually to be honest students who
take a year off I mean we call it taking
a year off right it's your kind of like
thought out is maybe someone who
couldn't take it or there's something a
little wrong with you so we haven't
really validated that that's an
appropriate thing to do but it's so
powerful when students do it so the next
thing that we did is we asked our
students to go get some inspiration from
beyond campus and in particular from
beyond formal educational environments
we really wanted to have them study
learning kind of in its essence outside
of school so we sent a group of students
who went to visit SpaceX to try to
understand how a really technical
company fosters collaboration and we
sent a group of students to go
behind-the-scenes at Cirque du Soleil
and they learned that even though the
performers in the show were really kind
of at the peak of their careers and
conditioning they were still required to
take classes and learn new things so
that they continued to learn and this
was really challenged for our students
what they had expected in terms of what
it means to be an expert in the world we
also had a group who went down to LA and
visited an organization called homeboy
industries and homeboy industries helps
provide services that help rehabilitate
people who have been in gangs and who
want to be enjoying a more productive or
mainstream life and in addition to kind
of tattoo removal and job training
services the organization has some
really fundamental principles baked in
so for one thing they don't do
recruitment or marketing you really have
to be ready and to show up when you're
ready to find them and secondly once
you're admitted you have to clear a drug
test but once you're admitted they
assign you an advisor and then you with
your advisor decide what combination of
classes you might want to take what's
the right path for you and they just
don't believe that there's just one path
to to navigate their offerings or to
find success and our students were
really inspired by both of these ideas
right showing up when you're ready and
being able to chart your own path and
they wondered why can't some of these
principles
be a bigger part of our college
experience so the work culminated this
past spring when after finding lots of
insights like these both from Stanford
and Beyond we shared our ideas with the
broader Stanford community and these
ideas were really meant to start
conversations in this very formal
environment and to inspire people to try
to think 10 or 15 years into the future
which is you know longer term time
horizon than we usually think with in
academia so I'm gonna share four of
these provocations with you today the
first is an idea that we called open
loop University so this idea really
boils down to the following concept if I
told you that you could exercise every
day
for the next four years and then at the
end of the four years you would be fit
for the rest of your life you would
laugh right you might be really happy to
hear that news but you would probably
laugh and essentially that's the model
that we have baked into college right we
give students one shot in early
adulthood to kind of learn what they
need to know and then we spit them out
into that side world but what if college
wasn't just a time in your life but it
lasted your whole lifetime right what if
instead of four years you actually had
six years of college to distribute over
the course of your life you could loop
out into the working world when you
needed some real experience and you
could loop back in to a university or
college when you needed some kind of
deeper learning experience so avocados
don't all ripen in exactly 8 days right
but we we somehow expect that kids are
all ready to go to college at 18 and
this was part of the provocation right
this was an idea for what an
advertisement might look like if
Stanford decided to adopt the open loop
university model the next idea was
around what we called paced education
what if actually we we created a system
where students could move through
college at their own pace so right now
college is just kind of arbitrarily
structured into four years and we know
that students show up with all different
skills and all different levels of
readiness
but we only really offer them one rhythm
and for a lot of students this means
that for instance they have to declare a
major before they have any real concept
of what it might be like to work in that
profession or do it or to study that
more deeply so what if college abolished
the class here and let students explore
and focus and practice we think actually
that these are the three basic phases
that students go through they need to
explore lots of topics in a light way to
find out what's right for them they need
to focus and deepen and gain expertise
in just one or two of them and then they
really need an opportunity to practice
to try and to fail and to try again
the third idea we called access flip so
we now live in a world where you can get
any piece of information basically that
you need at any time so what if college
in the future wasn't about accumulating
information but was really about
developing competencies and skills how
would you actually share what you'd
really learned at college with the
outside world in that scenario could the
college transcript be as unique as a
human fingerprint and really show and
emphasize the skills that you are
prepared to use going forward instead of
just being a record of the classes that
you've taken in the past the last idea
that I want to share with you today we
called purpose learning so one of the
things that is really a pleasure about
teaching at a college or university
today is that this generation is
incredibly committed and really
genuinely wants to do good in the world
so what if students declared missions
not majors or even better what if they
apply to the school of hunger or the
school of renewable energy these are
real problems that society doesn't have
answers to yet wouldn't that fuel their
studies with some degree of urgency and
meaning and real purpose that they don't
yet have today and our goal is that they
would feel as inspired and full of
purpose as these two students
so we started with this question can
higher education be redesigned but
actually I think that this is the wrong
question I think that the more important
and actually the much harder question is
to ask can it fundamentally be changed
right we remember that images of the
lecture halls this is a really old model
and and it will take a lot to disrupt
that paradigm where there is movement
starting to happen what's at the center
of the conversation is technology and
business models but I really think that
to create a new model of higher
education that prepare students for that
ambiguous uncertain world of the future
we have to do more as the creative
community and I really mean the
community in this room as designers I
think we need to be part of putting
students at the center of that
conversation thank you